it was entire career squashed by a
single stupid story in Rolling Stone
that's how easily it happens now was the
story stupid I mean did it have any
basis in fact an editor at rolling stone
told me that there were factual errors
in it and there's something weird about
it but yes people did die because yes
people die from using drugs occasionally
to deny that would be to lie but that
doesn't mean that they don't have
therapeutic activity and it doesn't mean
that they should be illegal one of the
ones that disturbs me the most is
fentanyl fentanyl just I don't even
understand why anybody would want to
make that it seems to me that we have no
any of opiates as it is why make one
that's a thousand times stronger than
heroin yeah I've known for fentanyl
chemists including the one that
introduced fentanyl to the United States
initially he died recently did he die
from it
no died of all day just killed so many
people yeah Tom Petty David Bowie
it was Bowie one I'm not sure prints
yeah I mean there's quite a few great
people that we've lost to this stuff
yeah it's really it's unfortunate but
again fentanyl is not the problem the
problem taking problem is people taking
it and the problem is lack of access to
safer opioids and lack of education
surrounding fentanyl because it doesn't
even really have desirable properties
you know one thing that people always
talk about the potency offense and one
thing that they don't often talk about
is the duration it's a very very short
duration opioid which necessitates
compulsive constant Rideau Singh if
you're addicted to fentanyl unless
you're doing a transdermal patch or
something like that you typically can't
make it through a single night without
having to reduce because the duration is
so short that's why it's always done in
these prolonged release formulations
like a lollipop that you suck or a patch
but anyway it's yet it's not a drug
that's well-suited to street use it's to
the therapeutic index is to narrow its
duration is to short it has a medical
purpose that it works very well for it
shouldn't be used as a heroin
replacement but the economic reality is
that you have to make heroin from opium
opium has to come from
place where poppies are grown that's a
whole process whereas fentanyl can be
made by one guy somewhere and the profit
margin on the fentanyl is so much
greater that there's an enormous
economic incentive and the first chemist
this guy that was sort of a friend of
mine the diet to do it considered it a
good thing to do that's the complexity
that you have to recognize it's so easy
to say that all these people are so bad
but often you don't know what's gonna
happen until it happens his idea was
that one of the major burdens of being
addicted to heroin is that you can't
afford it it's really expensive so by
substituting this relatively inexpensive
material the price of heroin would go
down this financial burden associated
with opioid addiction would be reduced
it would actually improve the quality of
life of the users and it could even be a
more pure potentially safer material if
you look at certain literature of course
that's not what happened and many people
died and he went to prison as a result
of it did he really yes why did he go to
prison for it because people died and it
was traced back to him Wow yeah so he
wasn't doing this in any sanctioned know
he was in clandestine chemist his name
was George Marquardt weird guy yeah I
guess yeah but anyway you know you just
don't know you don't know what's going
to happen until it happens you know of
course the legendary story that heroin
was introduced by Bayer as a
non-addictive alternative to morphine
they probably did think that was the
case at the beginning but history has
shown that that is not the case that's
one of the problems with introducing any
drug to a large population you simply
don't know it's and it's also one of the
things that I find most interesting in
and perhaps a silver lining in this
whole synthetic cannabinoid narrative
that's been playing out over the last
decade is you could say oh it's terrible
people should just smoke cannabis but
we're learning so much about what
cannabinoid receptor agonists can do
that we would have never learned if it
weren't for the widespread use of
synthetic cannabinoids I mean just for
instance that it is possible for high
potencies cannabinoid receptor agonist
to kill you that's a big one we didn't
know that until recently that they can
be addictive